Disney has made some of the greatest films
of all time.
From Mickey Mouse to Marvel to Star Wars,
Disney seems to be behind pretty much everything
that kids grow up loving to watch.
There are perhaps no Disney characters more
iconic than the Disney Princesses who represent
all that is good in this world.
There is a lot that is known about these Princesses
but there are some facts that deserved to
be uncovered and shared with everyone!
For this list we are taking a look at 10 Secret
Facts About Disney Princesses Kids Should
Know About!
Enjoy the video and be sure to hit that Subscribe
button for more awesome Screen Rant content,
every single day!
Elsa
If the words “Elsa”, “Frozen” or “Let
It Go” doesn’t ring a bell in your mind,
you have probably been living under a rock
since at least 2013.
The story follows Elsa and Anna on their snowy
adventures and Frozen is actually the first
movie to feature sibling Princesses.
Also, Elsa, who is supposed to be 21 in the
movie, is the oldest Disney Princess and the
only non-teenager of the official lineup.
Elsa’s blonde flowing hair is now a huge
part of her image but it turns out that she
wasn’t always supposed to looks that way.
Apparently, the concept art for Elsa had her
with short, spiky, black hair that gave her
a more edgy and alternative look.
In the end, the blonde hair turned out great
and we can’t imagine Elsa any other way!
Snow White
Released all the way back in 1937, Snow White
was the first feature length animated Disney
Movie the world got to see.
It comes as no surprise then that Snow White
was the first official Disney Princess but
what some fans may not know is that she also
remains the youngest Disney Princess of all
time at the age of only 14.
This young age was less weird in the 1930’s
but looking back now it seems a bit creepy
to have a super young teenager living alone
in the woods and then kissing a prince.
Sleeping Beauty
Sleeping beauty or Aurora was one of the first
official Disney Princesses that the world
got to fall in love with.
It seems like the creator of the movie may
have had a weird obsession with the number
eighteen.
What do we mean?
Well in the film Aurora actually only manages
18 minutes of screen time, the least of any
Disney Princess.
Additionally, Aurora only speaks 18 lines
of dialogue in the entire film, which is the
least by any lead character in a Disney film.
And would you like to guess how old Sleeping
Beauty is meant to be in her movie?
If you guessed 18…you are correct.
We’re not sure if this number means anything
but it’s definitely a fun fact!
Belle
Beauty And The Beast is one of the greatest
films that Disney has ever made, animated
or otherwise and the whole world is excited
to see Emma Watson take on the role of Belle
in the 2017 live adaption of the story.
There are a lot of things that make Belle
a unique Disney Princess such as a the fact
that she is the one to have her film nominated
for the Best Picture Academy Award and she
is the only Princess who has Hazel eyes.
One secret fact that many fans may not know
about Belle however is that she originally
had a younger sister, Clarice, who was not
in the final version of the movie because
the writers wanted to place a greater emphasis
on Belle’s loneliness.
Cinderella
Cinderella is one of the more iconic Disney
Princesses to ever come to the screen and
she was the first Princess to be given a live
Disney adaption in 2015.
We have heard stories of multiple actors trying
out for an iconic role before but did you
know that more than 400 actors auditioned
to be the voice of Cinderella for the 1950
animated film.
In the end Ilene Woods won the role and her
but it looks like Disney could have used some
of those other actors to help film a scene
that fans never got to see.
In a deleted scene from the film, Cinderella
dreams of an army of Cinderella’s to do
her chores and we think it could have been
cool to have given them different voices.
Jasmine
In the Disney classic, Aladdin, Jasmine is
the beautiful and cunning princess that ends
up falling for the street rat.
Jasmine is unique for a few reasons such as
the facts that her main outfit is not a dress
and that she is the only Princess who’s
name is not the title of her film but something
a lot of fans won’t know is that Jasmine
was originally going to be named Badroulbadour,
after the princess who marries Aladdin in
Arabian Nights.
This would have been a nice shout out to authenticity,
but Jasmine seemed like a much easier name
for kids to remember.
Another interesting fact about Jasmine was
that she was actually the first Disney Princess
to have separate speaking and singing voice
actors, something that has become common practice
in the Disney movies ever since.
Merida
Disney released Brave in 2012 and introduced
the world to the badass archer princess, Merida.
With her fiery red hair and spunky personality
there is no doubt that Merida was designed
by Disney to be a positive and inspiring role
model for young girls.
Need more proof?
Well, Merida was actually the first Disney
Princess without a love interest in her film
– talk about making a statement.
Merida’s creation turned out to be just
as complex as her personality as the animators
reported that her iconic curly red hairdo
is made up of 111,700 hairs that were generated
from over 1500 individually sculpted models.
The movie was a big-time hit, so it looks
like the hard work was worth it!
Rapunzel
In 2010, Tangled took the world by storm with
it’s creative and refreshing telling of
the classic Rapunzel fairy tale.
There were new characters and plot points
but the movie made sure to keep the classic
story aspects intact, such as Rapunzel’s
iconic long hair.
Fans have often wondered just how long the
golden blonde hair really is and Disney has
released an answer of 70 feet long, easily
the longest hair of any of the Disney Princesses.
An interesting fact about Rapunzel though
is that fter having her hair is cut in the
film she then becomes the Disney Princess
with the shortest hair of all time, taking
the spot away from Snow White.
Pocahontas
When Disney dropped the movie Pocahontas in
1995 they have the world some of the greatest
songs and action in any Disney animated film.
The cool thing about Pocahontas is that she
is the only Disney Princess who was actually
a real person, even though the film took some
serious liberties with her story and her age.
Many people believe that Pocahontas was the
first Native American princess to be shown
in a Disney film, but those people are unfortunately
forgetting about Tiger Lily from Peter Pan,
who may not be an official Disney Princess,
but is a princess in the film all the same.
Princess Leia
Although she is not on the official Disney
Princess lineup, Princess Leia is absolutely
a Princess and Disney does now own the rights
to Star Wars, so why not!
The late Carrie Fisher was absolutely iconic
in the role and it was an absolute joy to
see her reprise it in 2015’s The Force Awakens.
But many people don’t know that George Lucas
considered and even tested several dozen actresses
for the part of Leia.
Jodie Foster was an early front-runner, and
everyone from Glenn Close to Meryl Streep
tried out for the part.
In the end, Fisher landed the role and rest
is history.
Although she has recently passed away, the
world will be lucky enough to see her one
last time as she had already finished filming
her scenes for 2017’s Episode 8.
So there’s our list of 10 secret facts about
Disney Princesses that kids should know about!
How many of these facts took you by surprise?
Who do you think is the best Disney princess?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos – like this one!